I really hope you've enjoyed learning about how to
acquire personal genetic information in this lesson, and put it
to use. Let's see if we can summarize some of
these concepts into six main points. Point one, the decision
to acquire personal genetic information in the first place,
usually involves considerations of how that information can be used,
not just by you, but also by other people. Point
two. After consenting, a personal genome can be extracted, amplified,
and analyzed using nothing more than
a saliva sample. Point three. Ancestry information
can be obtained generally or more
specifically about the paternal and materal lines.
Point four. Family connections can be
inferred by comparing SNV compositions of related
individuals. Point five, individual SNVs can
reveal information about individual traits, inherited conditions,
and even particular responses to drugs. And point six, risk for
complex traits is usually evaluated by assessing multiple SNVs.